yeah hello guten tag Peter Peter Peter
welcome to the scariest and came ever is
the show that's not really a show just
an excuse for me to use hyperbolic Title
I we're playing one night one night five
night one night at Freddy's in VR oh my
god I don't know if this is a good idea
breasts oh [ __ ] oh my god yeah I'm
actually like the security guard guy I
didn't even answer the phone man those
drawings are [ __ ] badass oh cool how
do I change the cameras rocky click oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] me are they gonna come
right next to me no no I don't like that
oh [ __ ]
five nights at Freddy's actually scary
was no chica that [ __ ] [ __ ] I kept my
eye on hers for so long she's been
[ __ ] me for the longest time - where
is she she kept boom boom this is
fantastic
there she is she's in the kitchen on
their clothes Oh chica chica sexy [ __ ]
oh can you stop Bonnie
and here we are rich again son of a
[ __ ] as she sat over there read de
genève oh my god it's so scary it's
right next to me I don't like ya guys oh
thank god I'm actually [ __ ] their
father
oh so now it just gets harder that's
what she said oh where the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ]
let's yes in the kitchen the fast
chicken no shame on you chica shoo
[ __ ] [ __ ] bonnie bonnie you're not
invited
oh god oh god I [ __ ] hear her oh
that's so creepy
you can't just come up in my face [ __ ]
that's actually scary oh man
it should make all that fine as it is I
would actually enjoy it this is cool
oh god what's that sound does that mean
he's out there I don't I don't I don't
know what's going on I don't like it
alright how about that I just wanted to
be a security guard make five dollars so
I can support my family
oh god oh god oh god
look at my [ __ ] I have such good buns
this is [ __ ] hard course oh man let's
try one more I can handle one more Oh
normal medium hard ultra but it's ultra
I can't even normal can you imagine a
financier Fridays where you can walk out
and [ __ ] that would be cool too I think
[ __ ] like just have to charge up in
the shed what kind of lights what kind
of [ __ ] energy-saving piece of [ __ ]
plays it sticks we're soon we're wasting
so much energy doesn't mean making it
has any sense I never said I got it here
[ __ ] something where's Bonnie
where's Bonnie where's Bonnie where's
Bonnie
nice party [ __ ] cheek' suck in my ass
right now No alright alright alright
good for your chicken Bonnie you better
not be still out there
oh ok ok please don't hurt me I am
Swedish Oh God hello hello I quit my job
now I don't do this anymore
yes we can stop in here we ain't
stopping until the protein double
dippers popping hey how are you doing
great
I love you oh great they're all out
Bonnie you look so kawaai Freddie [ __ ]
bear
oh [ __ ] see that fog [ __ ] ah this is
going just terribly don't we love each
other and it's not that simple
well great Freddie [ __ ] raises shut-eye
here you know
oh my god it's so [ __ ] creepy